one dreaded disease receding and another
potentially on the rebound this week the
centers for disease control relaxed its
coronavirus quarantine guidelines
acknowledging that the disease is here
to stay but at the same time the virus
that causes polio which had not been
seen in the united states in nearly a
decade is now being detected in the
nation's largest city
elaine keanu is here with more on that
good morning elaine good morning
michelle health officials here in new
york city are urging parents and
pediatricians to get children vaccinated
against the potentially deadly disease
this after the presence of polio virus
has been detected in the city's
wastewater
public health officials are warning the
presence of polio virus in new york
city's wastewater means the disease is
likely circulating locally they're
urging those unvaccinated to get
immunized immediately in new york city
86 percent of kids five and under have
received three doses of the vaccine but
in some areas that number drops below 60
percent this comes just three weeks
after a man was paralyzed with polio in
rockland county new york the us's first
case in nine years officials fear
hundreds could be infected the likely
culprit vaccine hesitance the polio
vaccination rate in rockland county is
just 60 percent compared to the nearly
79 percent statewide
polio used to disable thousands mostly
children each year but was largely
eradicated in america through mass
vaccination programs starting in the
1950s
doctors say people need to be proactive
about making sure it doesn't spread if
we can go back to having
very very high standards with regard to
making sure that people are vaccinated
and making sure that the immunization
rates are better
that's our best method of protection
and most people who get polio do not
have visible symptoms about one in four
though develop flu-like symptoms
including fevers fatigue and headaches
and according to the cdc about 1 in 200
polio infections leads to paralysis so
doctors say you know the best protection
get vaccinated if you're not sure check
with your health care provider but
really this is something that they
eradicated once and they say they can do
it again people just need to get that
shot frightening to hear that it is back
elaine thank you